hello guys this is vikish and let's get
started with today's topic which is
about walking through a particular
project using all the concepts which we
have learned so far so in this session
we are going to focus on a particular
project and the project we are going to
focus is is about an ATM application so
you might have interacted with different
ATM Stores in your cities where you go
in you insert your card you enter your
PIN and then you can view the balance
you can withdraw some amount you can
also deposit some amount from the ATM so
we will try to look at it from that
perspective and and we will see what
kind of different uh Java and oops
Concepts we can use to build such ATM
application this is not a super
versatile application but but this is
just to give you the idea of how to use
those oops Concepts to build a simple or
a complex Java application so let's
start from the options menu class
because that will give us is the
understanding of what kind of
functionality I'm using and here you
will use that I am using different
concepts which I have taught you so far
in this particular Series so for example
we are using the io exception we are
using the hashmap class we are also
using a scanner class which is used to
take input from the command line so this
option menu class is extending the
account class and I will come to the
account class in a while but let's see
what this option menu class is doing
this particular class has uh it is using
a decimal format money format class
which is to denote what kind of format
of money you have then we have a hash
map which is storing the couple of
records of account number to pin mapping
so we create a map and inside the get
login method we add couple of entries to
the map here the first entry the first
integer is pointing to the customer
number and the second integer is
pointing to the pin of the account of
this particular customer number so if we
call the get login method this method
will insert the data after that it will
ask the customer to enter the customer
number which has to be one of these two
if you provide any other value then
there should be a logic in the
application to reject the input so
whatever a customer number the customer
inputs we pass that inside this
particular method called set customer
number again I will come back to that
and once you have provided a valid
customer number then this method is
going to ask you to enter a PIN number
and remember I told you this is the
customer number to the pin number
mapping so whatever customer number you
select from here you will be providing
the corresponding pin number and again
if you provide an invalid pin number you
will get an error so that will all
happen inside this try block and if you
enter any invalid characters in the pin
number or the ATM customer number then
you will get an exception which I am
writing inside the catch block this is
all what we have seen so far after the
successful enter of the customer number
and the PIN number I fetch those values
from these two methods again I will talk
about what these methods are doing and
again I'm doing some basic validation
checks but things get interesting in
this method so what we covered so far
was the get login method let me close
this method here so we covered the get
login method the second method which is
defined in this particular class is the
account type so here the we will ask the
once the customer has provided the
customer number and the pin number we
will ask the customer to provide the
account type this application supports
two different account types which are
checking account or a savings account so
whatever so the customer has to choose
one of them again we will be taking the
input from the command line using the
scanner class and then I'm using a
switch case if the customer entered one
then I will execute some code for the
checking account which is defined here
in the case one and if the customer
entered two then the case 2 will be
executed and if the if it enters three
then I will exit the application by just
printing assist out so here I'm using
the switch case construct to provide
different options to the customer
there's also a default case specified
here which says invalid choice so this
is what is happening in the get account
type method the next method is if the
customer has used the option one then we
call the get checking method so let's go
to the get checking method which is the
next method which is defined in this
particular class so if the customer has
selected a checking account then we
provide the following functionality to
the customer which is the customer can
view the balance customer can withdraw
the funds customer can deposit the funds
to the checking account or they can just
exit the application and again I'm using
a switch case here based on the customer
types one two three or four the
corresponding case block will be
executed for example if the customer
wants to view the balance then this
block will get executed and I call the
get account type method if the customer
selects the 2 as the withdrawal fund
then get checkings with withdraw input
method gets called and then get account
type gets called similarly if the
customer enters 3 then we deposit the
fund and for that also I have defined a
method I will go to the definition of
these methods as we go along but right
now we are just building the framework
so the get checking deposit input method
will be called to whenever the customer
selects the option three and for option
4 we just exit the application so this
is what is happening in the get checking
method now if from the account selection
if the customer selected second option
which was savings account then we were
calling get saving method so this is
where the get saving method is defined
and again it is following the exact same
format as we saw in the get checking
method where we present the following
options like viewing balance withdrawing
the funds and depositing the funds in
the savings account and I have some
methods defined here for example get
saving withdraw input get saving deposit
input so we Define the switch case here
based on the customer's choices here and
that is what is happening in the get
saving method so let me close this
method as well and that's all what is
defined inside the option menu class so
we asked the customer to enter the
customer number the pin number from this
get login method then based on that we
provide the customer the options to
choose the account type whether they can
choose the savings account or the
checking account and based on that
whatever account type they use we call
the get checking or get saving method
and inside this method we provide the
customer the other options to either
withdraw the money deposit the money or
view the balance that is what is
happening inside this option menu class
now let's go to the account class and
all the methods which we saw here will
be provided a definition in the account
class you also see this option menu is
extending the accounts class so an
inheritance concept is being used here
let's go to the account class now so
this is the account class where I have
defined some private member variables
like customer number so now you will be
familiar with the customer number pin
number which I just described and also
with the checking balance and the
savings balance you can also divide this
account class into two child classes
where you have a savings account class
and a checking account class but for
Simplicity I've kept it to one class I
am initializing a scanner input which
will be used at multiple places and then
I have the Setters and Getters for these
four member variables so you see set
customer number get customer number if
you remember this set customer number
was called in the option menu class if I
go back to the get login once we ask the
customer to enter the customer number we
call the set customer number which gets
called here similarly we call the set
PIN number which gets called here
similarly once we have said that we then
we were fetching the values using the
get customer number and the get pin
number and that has that is also defined
here in terms of the Getters get pin
number and get customer number similarly
we also have the Getters for the
checking balance and the saving balance
member variables we do not have the
Setters for them because they are not
technically Setters but we have to
calculate the balance it's not a simple
Setter where you can just return the
value so now let's look at some of the
business business functions of the
account class how do you deposit how do
you view the balance how do you withdraw
the balance Etc so you see these two
methods which are specifically when the
customer is trying to withdraw the money
from their account and these methods are
basically called internally by other
methods so we will come to that let's
see that let's just understand that we
have two methods for calculating the
withdrawal amount or executing the
withdraw transaction for the checking
account account and the savings account
similarly I have two more methods here
which are calculating the depositing for
the checking account and calculating the
depositing for the savings account and
then we get the the bigger methods which
are using these calculation methods so I
Define four calculation methods so far
calc checking withdraw calc saving
withdraw calc checking deposit and calc
saving deposit basically we're drawing
in deposit for both of the classes and
then we have these business functions
called get checking withdraw input and
get saving withdraw input get checking
deposit input and get saving deposited
so these getter methods are something
which were being called from the option
menu class if you remember if you go
back to the option menu class and if you
chose the checking account you get these
options and let's say you chose option
two which was withdraw funds or option 3
which was deposit funds then the
corresponding methods which were being
called were get checking withdraw input
and get checking deposit input and this
is the exact same method get checking
withdraw input and get checking deposit
input so if you see what is happening
inside this particular method is couple
of sellouts then we take the scanner
input amount and which we convert that
amount to the double after that we check
if the amount which the customer wants
to withdraw is smaller than the checking
balance or not and I'm running this
condition to check that if the amount is
smaller than the checking balance then
we call the Cal checking which draw
method which was defined right here
remember I told you that these four calc
methods will be used and this is how
they are used so here I'm actually
subtracting the value so whatever amount
the customer wants to withdraw subtract
that from the main balance and then
return the new main balance that's what
you do right if you have thousand rupees
and if you want to withdraw 500 you
subtract 500 from thousand and then you
send back the remaining balance so that
is what is happening when we call this
method and then we print the new
checking account balance that is what is
happening in the get checking withdraw
input method similarly if you chose
option 3 which was depositing funds to
the checking account then get checking
deposit input gets called and it is
defined right here get checking deposit
input and here instead of subtraction we
are doing the addition so here I'm again
doing a condition check that the current
balance plus the new amount which has
been supplied by the customer from the
command line the total sum of it should
be greater than zero what if the
customer entered an amount minus five
thousand I should not allow that so
that's the reason I'm putting this
condition in place and if the current
balance plus the new amount which is
supposed to be deposited to the account
the sum of it is greater than zero then
call the calc checking deposit method
and this is where the calc checking
deposit method is present and we are
just doing present balance plus the new
amount and returning the New Balance
that's all which is being done here and
you will see exactly similar logic
running for the savings account as well
if you look at the get saving withdraw
input which is used to withdraw money
from the savings account so I take the
input from the command line and I run a
condition check that the amount which
the customer wants to withdraw should be
less than the current saving accounts
balance if yes then call calc serving
saving withdraw method which is defined
here where I subtract the amount from
the current balance and I return the new
balance and similarly you will see the
exact same functionality in the get
saving deposit where we add the money
instead of subtracting the money and
this is all what is defined in the
account class so we talked about the
option menu class we talked about the
account class and now we have the ATM
class which is the entry point which
basically initializes the option menu
class and calls the get login method
remember get login was the first method
which asked you to provide the customer
number and then get login called the
method to choose the account type and
the account type methods then called the
method to choose the option to withdraw
deposit or exit so now we have built a
fair understanding of what is happening
in this application so let's run this
application so I just ran this
application and let me bring the console
here it's first asking for a customer
number so I will go to the option menu
class and I will pick up one of the
customer number which I have hard coded
here so I will provide that customer
number and hit enter then it asks me for
the PIN number so remember you have to
provide the correct pin number
corresponding to the customer number so
I'm taking this pin number just copying
it and pasting it here then this whole
code got executed and then it called the
get account type and the get account
type method provided you with these
options which you see here on the screen
so based on what you select the case
block will get executed and let's say I
want to go for a checking account so I
press 1 and I hit enter once you select
the checking account the case one gets
selected and it calls the get checking
method and the get checking method again
provides you with another menu to
withdraw view view withdraw or deposit
or exit so let's say I want to deposit
funds so I press 3 and hit enter it says
the current balance is 0 and enter the
amount you want to deposit let's say I
want to deposit 500 and I hit enter you
get the message saying the new checking
account balance is 500 and you have
successfully deposited the money and
that is what I did for the checking
account now let's try to withdraw
something from the taking account so you
again get back the same option because
inside the get checking method we call
the once we have successful fully done
the business operation we again call the
account type method to display the menu
again to the user so let's say again
select the checking account class and
this time I want to withdraw the funds
remember I've added 500 there so let's
say I want to withdraw so I choose the
option 2 as the choice current balance
is 500 and it's asking me the amount you
want to withdraw from the checking
account so I enter let's say 100 and I
hit enter when I do that the new
checking account balance becomes 400 so
the 100 got subtracted from the 500 and
the new balance is shown to your screen
you can do exactly the same thing for
for the savings account as well and
let's also run a negative condition so I
again select the checking account and I
want to withdraw the funds so I choose
the option two current balance is 400
and I I would like to withdraw thousand
what happens if you do that we get a
message saying balance cannot be
negative and this is coming from the
calc checking method which which is
defined here so what is happening that I
wanted to with draw the funds from the
checking account and here get checking
withdraw input dot called here this
condition was checked so the checking
balance was 400 and the amount I wanted
to withdraw was 1000 so 400 minus 1000
is not greater than equal to zero so it
jumped into the else block and it said
balance cannot be negative so this is
how you can also build some error
conditions in your code which are
mandatory and which should be built
otherwise your application will have lot
of bugs we can also exit the application
so if you just type 3 and hit enter you
will exit from the application and it
will come in it will again call the
login method where it will again ask you
to enter the customer number so this is
how you can run this application and
this is this was a simple use case for
you to show how you can use the
different object-oriented Concepts like
classes objects methods Setters Getters
switch case
Etc to build the application with the
correct business logic and this is all I
want to cover in this particular session
and in the next session we are going
going to have a look at another
interesting core Java project just to
build our understanding more better
about the core Java concept and if you
like this video a thumbs up would be
massively appreciated and please don't
forget to subscribe for more programming
related videos thank you and we'll meet
again in the next session
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here